hi i'm jerry gionis your new favorite
australian i'm so excited to bring you
this bts video of my experience with
nikon's flagship mirrorless camera the
z9 as one of the first in the world to
try this i can't wait to share this
video with you now i'm a nikon
ambassador i can't call this a review
i'm simply sharing my experience with it
enjoy
hi i'm jerry gionis a portrait fashion
and wedding photographer and filmmaker i
have had one of the best weeks of my
life and i've spent it with the nikon z9
nikon's flagship mirrorless camera ever
since the nikon z6 and the z7 i've been
all in with mirrorless all in and all
eyeballs were on this camera after a
week with the z9 i'm telling you it is
amazing i was given this camera
and here's an assignment do what you do
jerry i'm like i have portraits i
photograph weddings fashion performers
and i want to explore every single genre
so last five days
we've been photographing all these
different things and it's come at the
right time in my life too because the
last year and a half i have done so much
more filmmaking than in my entire career
my video partner jason neistat we
actually worked together and we've
developed an incredible crew we've shot
music videos this year we shot
documentaries we've shot short little
films
and all of a sudden i've got this 8k
video that i can actually play with and
it is a serious option for the actual
incredible filmmakers out there that
want something amazing with incredible
glass incredible color straight out of
camera now let me talk to you about the
week that we've actually had so sunday
night we're photographing in low light
this very very dark and moody dramatic
location and i tested out the low light
focus and it was amazing and that's what
you'd expect from a flagship camera we
photographed at 6 400 iso
10 000 iso
so if you can imagine the exposure and
how dark this was and we use eye
autofocus
and we tested out the auto area af
the small area af the large area af it
locked on focus very very quickly we use
existing light i photographed uh wyatt
underneath the lamp or like 6 400 iso
every single time it was in focus we
also can shoot 4k at 120 frames a second
in slow mo i'm getting shots that i
never would be like i've never gotten
before in my career the color straight
out of camera of course is incredible i
think nikon is famous for getting true
color out of camera so we photographed
wedding and fashion that first evening
and it was incredibles exhilarating and
then we spent the next the second and
third days shooting a music video
so ashley amber an incredible artist
that we've actually filmed before in a
few music videos was amazing and what we
did is we tested it so what do you do
when you have 8k well first of all you
need a bit of hard drive space but it's
worth the quality guys it's 8k
if you're photographing an entire scene
you can literally
halve your entire area and you're still
getting 4k
that is absolutely incredible now the
first location it looked like we're in
the back of a clock tower we were
actually doing a couple of different
keyframes so we're going from her face
being completely lit
and auto area af
and then we slid all around and did a
keyframe where it turned back into her
silhouette and it still kept focus if
you're photographing a silhouette which
we did of ashley in front of that clock
tower for example it grabbed focus it
grabbed the contrast it actually knew
what we were doing gives me confidence
it gives me freedom
and again that liberates me that i can
spend more time focusing on engaging my
client
more time on my composition my
creativity letting the camera really
worry about the focus i know i'm going
to get great color i know i'm going to
get an incredible file optics is
undeniable but putting all of these
features in an incredible body and being
able to achieve all these different
things and if you're a filmmaker you've
got 4k slow-mo you've got 8k
you've got i focus
you've got everything that you can rely
upon on the second day with ashley amber
we actually photographed and filmed in
this grand staircase it was beautiful it
was really amazing but it really lended
itself to actually testing how far we
could push the capabilities of using the
eye autofocus and we can again spend
more time directing and bringing out the
best in her we actually put a slider
right in the middle of the staircase and
slid right in and kept focused on her
the entire time then i thought to myself
wait a second let me test this even
further so what we did is we actually
had ashley sit down on the staircase and
then we had this beautiful ornate little
banister and and staircase and the eye
would jump across the bars of this
ornate framework and keep the focus the
entire time so we tested that and again
to be able to do that
having a slider left and right and
actually change the plane of focus and
continue that that would be very very
difficult for a human being to actually
do
with a little focus pool and looking at
a monitor so that was incredible really
loved that then we ended up getting her
on
on the balcony that was the last couple
of shots this beautiful bokeh that we
actually had
and it was just beautiful it rendered
the colors beautifully and it was so
much fun and i can't wait for you to see
the finished product then we come to our
fourth day and we're photographing this
incredible couple and as soon as i met
them i just fell in love with both of
them they're a beautiful couple they
just mix in really well and i they they
felt to me like you've got this
beautiful dark-skinned princess and then
you've got this
this old-school cool vibe and rockstar
and a day off type of vibe and i quickly
had all these photographs in my head now
i've been in love with the cpu picture
control sepia is monotone it's glorified
tones of brown and white but the cpu
picture control actually desaturates the
image and adds sepia it just mutes the
colors and gives us this really earthy
flavor we had an incredible time we shot
beautiful portraits
and that was just the morning then we
photographed wasa this incredible
designer she's an ex-humanity performer
she's from african descent she's just
really proud of her heritage and i'm in
love with her
all her designer wear like let's
actually photograph you
and
celebrate your heritage let's celebrate
everything about you she didn't go
halfway with this she was wearing 100
year-old leather garments that she
hand-sewed incredibly this incredible
outfit and we photographed her and again
the colors were spectacular rendering
her skin tone was absolutely beautiful
and then i said to her i said i then
want to photograph you um presuming
skittles just threw up on a photograph i
want all the color in the world in this
photograph it was absolutely perfection
now while we were there i'm like okay
to this point i didn't quite test can
the eye autofocus keep up
at 20 000 iso at 200 speed at
f2 or 1.2 and 1.8 and she was moving her
head left and right forward and back
even scooching down away from the camera
and bringing her head up she was turning
around as she was turning her face
around
the eye autofocus kept the focus on her
head she turned around and banged it
went on the eye again so again i'm
getting these shots that i've never
really gotten before because i can
totally trust and have confidence in
this new technology now i've got
goosebumps i don't know if you can see
this closely we hired
uh incredible performers i'm like let me
test this properly so here we are
the very camera that you're actually
seeing me on right now we use this
slider left and right front and back
with the performance we photograph
different angles we photographed into
flair into smoke and could the eye
autofocus catch up we had
luca one of the best brake dancers in
the world
and he was so passionate he was so into
his art it was absolutely exhilarating
inhaling the atmosphere and the energy
of the room and giving everything to
this shoot i grew up in the 80s so
seeing him do the helicopter and jumping
up and down and doing flips then i heard
the specs and i didn't believe it until
i did it photographing at 120 frames a
second i can't fathom that basically
press the shutter i'm at photographing
an f 1.2 f 1.8
at a thousandth of a second with an
electronic shutter now that i'm
photographing performers especially the
last year year and a half
why would i gamble with the peak of
flight i'm going to photograph at 120
frames a second and have a look and
guess what i would go back and it almost
looked like a an eight millimeter short
film so one it was actually really fun
to see but i could just choose the best
shot rather than actually be a bit more
prude with how many photographs that i
take there i was photographing these
incredible tap dancers john shawn are
world-class athletes i've seen them
perform i didn't actually realize who
they were but i've seen shows without
performing in there and i love the art
form but their joy they've got this
old-school swagger with this
contemporary charm and to hear them tap
and and
they're just perfectionists and that's
what i love about them is that they just
they expect a lot of themselves and i'm
photographing 20 photographs
in one second and again i would simply
go back
and look at the peak of their flight and
i know i've nailed it i'm like i took
the shots and i look around i'm looking
left and right like guys
i'm sort of done do i
i've already got gold here what do i do
here and again i'm getting shots that i
never would normally get
so we filmed natalya this incredible
dancer with this cylinder sort of going
left and right and forward and back uh
absolutely beautiful it focused on her
eye even past these cylinders that are
going left and right around her which i
found extraordinary and it rendered the
colors beautifully too so there it was
i'm photographing marina the ballerina
now in this particular environment as
you can see with smoke all around
you would one would consider this to be
hard to focus but the eye autofocus kept
it every single time i just have to
click the shutter
let the camera do the heavy lifting and
life is good i think gone the times
where you might photograph 10 frames
especially in full length and hoping
that maybe one or two might be in focus
how much can we rely and have confidence
in the nikon flagship mirrorless camera
the z9 and i'm telling you
we can as a wedding photographer i have
confidence that this camera can perform
in low light at ridiculous isos
catch contrast catch focus and it's been
the camera that we've been really
waiting for and yearning for this is the
one guys as a portrait photographer i
can put an eye autofocus put my camera
on a tripod engage my clients and know
that the camera can focus at cello depth
of field at 1.2 and 1.8 and all those
kinds of things as a fashion
photographer i get the colors that i'm
wanting and those beautiful colors that
again nikon is famous for and now that
i've actually been photographing
performers last couple of years i'm
capturing these incredible athletes
these world-class athletes in full
flight at the peak of their performance
and i can do that now with full
confidence and as a filmmaker and
developing my filmmaking skills the last
couple of years i can tell you that
actually filming in 8k
in camera with no need of another device
is absolutely incredible all i can say
guys that you've got to check out this
camera because to be able to create all
of these shots in one week and test it
out fully and it did not fail once
that is what i've been waiting for
that's what you've been waiting for but
i hope you enjoyed the images that we
shared the films that we shared
and remember you don't have to be the
best you simply have to be better than
last week
hope you enjoyed that video guys if you
want to learn more from me click on the
link above or in the description below
to access a free two-hour tutorial on
photography tips and tricks including
posing and lighting and if you liked it
please give me a thumbs up also
subscribe if you haven't subscribed if
you want to see more of these videos
make sure you click on the bell to get
notifications when i release a new video
and of course please comment so we can
connect in the future thank you so much
guys and goodbye from your favorite
australian